[Music]
hey hurry up before
somebody sees us you know your husband
drives a goober I don't look at me I'm
just a sod Nick I'm gonna suck the
out them titties later I promise
this is Jamal don't nobody leave
voicemails text me bitch I met Lolo's
Jamal I told you I was doing a special
open my jets for you you better be out
there smooches are you
ready for your next spoken word artist
give it up for generica but don't Sabu
how y'all feel my step MiG's on the
low-low this one's for you
Jamal I'm in tired of your
we ain't never seen in public
[Applause]
sit your more gear down and every time I
come around
they say you ain't here dead all you way
out of town but you don't like they
don't fit with kiddies in the bag I
think I'm tired of call it your mouth
nigga I'm bout to be gone
check out Jarvis what the you doing
here what can I got a tank yeah
I can't have a Sabu
[Music]